Một mê mề sảo tháng 1 năm 2018, công an tính hả tính phát thường báo hình, trên tìm chân chỉ bảo,
sinh năm 2018, chú thong tà suyên, sát thần dân cố, này thục xả đức họ, tính hả tính,
nghĩ cân lên quan vụ cứ tệ sản sế ra tối nè mề bốn tháng 1 năm 2018, tệ phường năm
lính. Đà điểm đến giả. Năm giới, cao khoảng 1 mế sống mê đến bệ mười, chân trái bị thương,
bùng đồ gối đạch trị mẫu. Chào phật ký bảo chốn, quần đui, áo khó tối mẫu, đi chân chân,
dí chuyển bằng đường bộ, tệng báo, đối tự ui hiện có thể mang động. Nó rất không tự ý tiếp cận,
khi phát hiện báo ngay chúng ta phàn quốc hội phó trường phòng cạnh rất hiện sự,
khó chính một hài bởi sấu, tắm, chính bởi tắm,
theo tả lệ định đến đối trường phòng cạnh rất hiện sự, khó chính một bởi tắm, bốn,
hài bà, sấu, tắm, hoặc không ăn đưa gần nhất.